[Applauso]
il cambiamento più rapido farà sorpresa
non avviene attraverso mezzi tecnologici
ma di avere nostro cervello non esiste
alcun macchinario e col robot in grado
di reagire i millesimi di secondo a uno
stimolo la nostra mente riesce a farla
se vuoi camminate per delle scale
inciampate riprendete l'equilibrio lo
dovete a questo meccanismo
un meccanismo che preistorico primitivo
ma che permette di avere una reazione i
millesimi di secondi che ci salva da una
caduta che ci permette di non investire
un bambino che attraversa la strada
mentre noi guidiamo al tempo stesso quel
qualcosa che ci fa rabbrividire
quando arriva uno stimolo spaventoso
perché questo è il meccanismo della
paura
parlare di cambiamenti rapidi pertanto
dal mio punto di vista ci induce a
riflettere su quella parte dell'essere
umano che è in grado di percepire le
cose e di reagirà le cose di elaborare
le cose ma uno dei vizi storici
dell'occidente e anche della scienza
occidentale e sulla base della filosofia
antica pensare che il pensiero venga
prima di qualunque cosa
oggi le neuroscienze ci dimostrano
concretamente quello che devo dire
da un punto di vista sperimentale
empirico avevamo già sperimentato fino
da oltre 35 anni fa curando trattando
con successo i disturbi più gravi come
le ossessioni compulsive l'anoressia e
il panico
che oltre all 80 per cento delle nostre
attività mentali si svolge al di sotto
della coscienza mentre la coscienza
rimane un mito abbiamo sentito anche
prima
un interessante commento le nostre
reazioni meccanici agiscono prima del
pensiero non deve stupire l'azione viene
prima del pensiero hines phone fester e
un grande scienziato diceva se vuoi
vedere impara ad agire quindi noi
dobbiamo imparare a gestire il nostro
modo di sentire il nostro modo di agire
per imparare a reagire agli stimoli nel
modo più funzionale evitando le modalità
disfunzionali una delle modalità più
disfunzionali che viene applicata da
sempre pensare che io devo fare tutto
guidato dalla luce assolutamente
cristallina della coscienza
la coscienza nella maggioranza dei casi
è un impedimento al cambiamento e non un
vero del cambiamento anzi come i miei
maestri
mi hanno insegnato anni fa la coscienza
e dove risiedono le maggiori resistenze
al cambiamento perché se si parla di
cambiamento non si può non parlare del
rovescio della sua medaglia la
resistenza al cambiamento tanto più noi
siamo protesi a un cambiamento tanto più
dentro di noi si innescano delle
reazioni contro il cambiamento in
biologia si chiama omeostasi un
equilibrio che una volta raggiunto tende
a mantenersi e gli equilibri mentali
sono quelli più rigidi ora ma siccome
abbiamo visto che la nostra mente può
rispondere ai millesimi di secondi in
modo apparentemente incoscienza
perché a me piace parlare di incoscienza
educata quando un atleta con alcuni di
quelli che ho avuto il piacere di
seguire rispondono in un duello di sera
ma i millesimi di secondi all'attacco
non rispondono pensando perché se
pensassero arriverebbero il ritardo
rispondono per un meccanismo di educata
incoscienza un addestramento reiterato
che porta ad avere una consapevolezza
operativa che non è coscienza e presenza
nell'atto agire ma non cosciente la
coscienza un'astrazione intellettuale
che si distacca da quello che è in corso
non ci fa fare meglio quello che in
corsa poi la coscienza è molto utile
prima e dopo la prestazione quando io
devo pianificare sulla base delle
esperienze allora rifletto analizzo
coscientemente quando dopo una
prestazione
rifletto su cosa è accaduto e ne
ricostruisco gli effetti quindi come
vedete tornano alla mente le parole di
einstein quando ci dice oggi abbiamo
bisogno di un nuovo modo di pensare per
risolvere problemi creati dal vecchio
nuovo di pensare il vecchio modo di
pensare pensare che il pensiero venga
prima di tutto e che domini tutto oggi
per fortuna gli studi più avanzati di
psicologia di neuroscienza di
psicoterapia inducono e dimostrano che
le nostre risposte più importanti sono
fondamentalmente di tipo emozionale non
più razionale sapete che i due premi
nobel per la eco nomia psicologi thaler
e cane ma non hanno proprio preso il
premio nobel dimostrando che oltre
l'ottanta per cento delle decisioni
fredde e lucide di un economista in
realtà sono prese sfasci emozionale
immaginate quello che noi facciamo tutti
i giorni quello che
produce il cambiamento ultra rapido nel
modo di sentire e di agire è quello che
un famoso studioso degli anni quaranta
france alexander aveva definito
esperienza emozionale correttiva
ovvero quel tipo di esperienza concreta
che una persona e sperimenta realmente
che gli fa sentire anche solo per un
attimo una percezione totalmente diversa
della realtà gli cambia la prospettiva
nel mondo orientale la chiamano
illuminazione ma quello di solito è
l'effetto di un percorso reiterato nel
tempo di meditazione invece l'esperienza
emozionale correttiva qualcosa che
accade continuamente abbiamo visto
quelle foto che colpiscono ma quello che
quelle foto producono in chi le vede
sono proprio sensazioni sensazioni forti
che possono per alcuni trasformarsi in
esperienza emozionale correttiva essere
folgorati sulla via di damasco
ci ricorda qualche testo sacro
l'esperienza emozionale correttiva è
qualche cosa che oggi attraverso studi
reiterati sperimentali a livello in
bilico può essere prodotto
tecnologicamente ovvero sono state messe
a punto tutta una serie di tecnologie
chiamate tecnologie terapeutiche io le
chiamo tecnologie psicologiche che
possono permettere di guidare le persone
a sperimentare esperienze emozionali
correttive che le fanno uscire dalle
loro rigide trappole mentali e badate
bene trappole mentali possono essere
quelle del soggetto che ha un grave
disturbo o quelle del manager fissato in
una idea o quello dello scienziato
innamorato della sua scoperta e non se
ne schioda più o dell'atleta bloccato
nella sua performance
quindi lo stiamo parlando solo di un
mero ambito ma stiamo parlando di un
ambito estremamente importante che
rimette la persona al centro di quello
che lo studio del cambiamento e dei
cambiamenti rapidi
proprio perché oggi abbiamo le prove
concrete che i cambiamenti rapidi si
possono realizzare anche in situazioni
che una volta si pensavano inamovibili
oppure che richiedessero tempi
lunghissimi per essere modificate però
badate bene ogni medicina all'eccesso
diventa un veleno ogni veleno in formato
ridotto diventa una medicina che cos'è
che induce le persone a cambiare
l'esperienza emozionale correttiva ma
come si induce una persona a fare
qualcosa che magari fino allora non ha
avuto l'ardire di fare non ha avuto la
capacità di sperimentare attraverso
certe forme di comunicazione e qui
torniamo indietro nel tempo torniamo
alla retorica della persuasione e le
suggestioni ipnotiche all arte della
persuasione ma quando allora parliamo di
tecnologia tecnologia che arriva in un
attimo e con un click
nel mondo oggi si renda ancor più
necessario pensare come la comunicazione
abbiamo potere straordinario nel creare
esperienze emozionali correttive e come
questa debba essere utilizzata con grano
salis come si dice con sale in zucca e
che non sia né un'improvvisazione né un
qualcosa di eccessivamente irrigidito su
posizioni moralistiche di censura non si
può fermare il cambiamento il
cambiamento e costante lo dicevano gli
antichi oltre 4000 anni fa però lo
possiamo cavalcare la comunicazione non
si può evitare
si comunica comunque l'influenza mento
non può essere evitato nel bene e nel
male quindi non è che limitando
censurando delle cose si riducono i
rischi
tutt'altro anzi ormai penso che la
maggioranza di chi ha un minimo di
esperienza studiato un po sta che ogni
volta che si proibisce una cosa la si
renda ancora più desiderabile quindi né
se incrementa la presenza non si riduce
oggi lavorare sulla comunicazione ci
riporta qualche cosa che più che moderno
e molto antico imparare l'uso del
linguaggio della comunicazione per sua
storia che calzi a certi scopi quindi
più impariamo utilizzare a comunicare in
modo strategico che per ottenere certi
scotti anche se questo può sembrare
manipolatorio ma persuadere condurre
soavemente a sé manipolare a forzare con
le mani sono due cose completamente
differenti più impariamo a essere
persuasori e più impariamo essere capace
attraverso la persuasione di indurre
elementi e comportamenti nelle direzioni
più funzionali per l'umanità più
riusciremo a cambiare il mondo
come indica lo taglia mag anti se vuoi
cambiare il mondo
comincia con migliara rete stessa grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]